clean your ass next question hi my name
is marie i'm lebanese american
hey i'm layla i'm lebanese
palestinian-american
hi i'm comedian alyssa durie i'm from
kuwait
my name is michael kamal i'm palestinian
and today i'm going to be answering
commonly googled questions about
arabs is it a rub
or is it aerobic arab me i'm
arab the language is arabic dance move
is arabesque a coffee is arabica
arab is the people arabic is the
language
arab is a people arabic is language i am
arab
and my family speaks arabic it's the
language and then the people
i'm right on that right that's right
yeah like yeah
is arab the same as middle eastern
arabs are middle eastern but middle
eastern doesn't equal arabs
it's kind of like that thing of a square
is a rectangle but a
no or whatever it is middle eastern is a
blanket term for like many different
ethnicities you can be persian you can
be assyrian
you can be kurdish a lot of the language
around the middle east and
arabs is really complicated and loaded
and it comes with a lot of baggage
that's one reason why i like to say
southwest asia and north africa it
connects us all through the things that
keep us similar
while focusing more on a geographical
location are arabs considered
white oh i knew this
question was going to come up if you ask
me i'm
not white i personally do not consider
myself white
and people generally get that i'm from
some middle eastern
area there are arabs who who are white
or who look white so for example i have
people in my extended family that have
blonde hair and blue eyes
and if you didn't know their names you
would not think they were arab at all
according to the u.s census arabs
are meant to check the white category
when arabs first came
to the u.s in 1870s pushed out
of greater syria by the ottomans
and had to prove because of the
exclusion act
that they were not asians and could stay
in this country
so those people said look at us we're
from the holy land we're christians
we could be white decades later
the diversity of arabs in the us has
been
much more expanded and so it's been
really problematic because the u.s
census doesn't account for who we are
we're a much larger population
that can't accurately be measured
because the census doesn't have a
category for us so we get lumped in
with those who are white and so now
there is a concerted effort by activists
and advocates all around the country to
have a designation for
people who identify as being arab or
more broadly middle eastern
why do arabs use bidets
i have been wanting one but i think it
doesn't it doesn't have anything to do
with me being arab
for the arabs that are muslim they do
use bidets in order to be clean
especially before prayer and for the
rest of us especially lebanese
it's because we bougie af because you
have to wash your ass
like clean your ass next question
do arabs eat pork this
arab does do not show this video to my
dad but
many arabs do not all arabs come from
religions that prohibit eating pork
don't worry about what i'm eating what
do arabs wear
herbs wear all sorts of stuff these are
funny like
well today i'm wearing just a black
t-shirt
and some shorts that i actually cut up
because these are pants that i didn't
really want anymore but i didn't want
them to go away so
that's what this arab wears uh depends
on the region
there's lots of different clothing that
is indigenous
to each different place i mean there's a
huge
part of the planet covered by arab
countries so
in each different place people wear all
sorts of different things and then don't
forget there are arabs in the diaspora
who are wearing whatever it's normal to
wear
where they live is arab the same as
persian
no arab is not the same as persian
persians are people that come from
iran iran is in the middle east but iran
is not an arab country
i get this question a lot especially as
a palestinian people are always like
oh are you persian are you pakistanian
no
no no persian pakistani and palestinian
are
three different ethnicities three
different locations
to all arab countries speak arabic
i actually don't know this and i'm not
going to claim to know this but i'm
assuming like yes
and most arab countries speak arabic
but often there's like french influence
and often they're educated in
english as well all arab countries speak
arabic but
in most of arab countries especially
those
who have been occupied or colonized by
other countries in their history
there's several different languages
spoken there's usually another primary
language
along with it sometimes that's an
indigenous language
in a lot of north africa there are so
many cool different languages i
highly encourage you to check out and
learn about where do arabs come from
abs come from a lot of places a magical
place
when a mommy arab and a daddy arab love
each other
very much our mother's wombs
they can come from the gulf north africa
sudan
the levant and there's arabs in america
that are born in america
they're from all over what does arab
america mean
this means so many things to so many
different people i'm arab american
because
my mom is from america and my dad is
arab i'm still trying to figure that out
i'm still trying to figure out if i am
if i can call myself arab american
it also is that because i'm an arab in
america
some people distinguish between arab
american and arabs in america
to me arab american means somebody who
considers themselves
both arab and american in whatever
capacity makes sense to them look i wear
being arab on my sleeve to the point
where people probably think i'm totally
obnoxious
like we get it you're arab but i get
kind of self-conscious feeling like
am i the right one to educate this
person on this in my experience
these questions have come from a place
of curiosity i'm glad that they feel
safe enough to ask me those questions
and they want to learn more
i would recommend asking people for
resources if they have any or
give it a quick google
you